[Music]
before we start this video I just wanted
to mention that only 14% of you have
subscribed so if you enjoy the content
please hit the subscribe button hey
everyone welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
were going to be discussing the auras of
the Harry Potter series
more specifically the five most powerful
auras auras are of course members of an
elite and highly trained unit of Magical
Law Enforcement they work for the
Department of Magical Law Enforcement in
the Ministry of Magic and are trained to
investigate dark crimes and detain dark
witches and wizards auras are
responsible for handling all matters of
dark magic and they aren't exempt from
having to deal with the likes of
powerful dark figures like Voldemort and
Grindelwald auras could be comparable to
elite muggle national law enforcement
officials or military units like mi5 or
mi6 think James Bond or our headquarters
are located on level 2 of the Ministry
of Magic pictures of known dark Wizards
maps clippings from The Daily Prophet
and other investigative materials lined
the walls of their cubicles becoming an
aura is no easy task and requires
thorough demonstration of top-tier
magical capabilities before you are even
initially considered your academic
credentials must be an excellent
standing additionally you need to have
completed at least 5 mutes nastily
exhausting Wizarding tests in
challenging subjects the recommended
newts are potions defense against the
dark arts Transfiguration apology and
charms the final grade on these newts
cannot be lower than exceeds
expectations becoming an aura is also
highly competitive and the following
excerpt from the order of the Phoenix by
McGonagall truly speaks to that you'd
need top grades for that said Professor
McGonagall extracting a small dark
leaflet from under the mass on her desk
and opening
they ask for a minimum of five newts and
nothing under exceeds expectations grade
then you would be required to undergo a
stringent series of character and
aptitude tests at the ORA office it's a
difficult career path Potter they only
take the best in fact I don't think
anybody has been taken on in the last
three years on top of the academic side
of things
prospective auras need to prove their
strength of character this is done by
participating in a number of aptitude
tests which tests how well they perform
under pressure these tests involve
transformation tests and stealth tests
in the order of the Phoenix
Tonks mentions to Harry that she passed
the transformation tests without any
difficulty no surprises there but had a
hard time with the stealth tests so
becoming Nora is no easy task and it
truly speaks to your charisma
intelligence ability to act under
pressure and your outright magical
capabilities because of this anyone who
achieves the rank of aura is no scrub
and has proven that they are the upper
echelon of Wizarding Society in terms of
magical power but who are the most
powerful of the auras in just a moment
I'm going to be ranking the top five but
before we get started it's worth
mentioning that constructing this list
wasn't so easy the auras of this list
have all demonstrated considerable power
and aptitude in a number of different
ways and so I'm sure the list could be
arranged according to your own
perspective number five John Dawlish
John Dawlish is a British pureblood
wizard and Ministry of Magic employee
Dawlish has been described by Dumbledore
himself as an excellent aura which are
filled by itself warrants stole Ash's
position on this list Dumbledore is
perhaps the most powerful Wizard of all
time
so this compliment should not be taken
lightly Dawlish worked directly
underneath Cornelius fudge and
accompanied him on various assignments
Dawlish would also later work for
ministers Rufus Scrimgeour
and pius thickness while studying to
become an aura
Dawlish achieved the rating of
outstanding on all of his newts
performing above the already lofty
exceeds expectations threshold that is
required
Dawlish attended Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry and
was recruited to the Ministry of Magic
at the age of 17 Dawlish along with
Shaka bolt escorted fudge to
Dumbledore's office where fudge accused
tumbled or of treason against the
Ministry of Magic
Dawlish though powerful is clearly no
match for Dumbledore himself and was
completely unable to prevent Dumbledore
from departing his office
Dawlish was posted in Hogsmeade during
the second Wizarding war to prevent
Hogwarts from being attacked by Death
Eaters and he was also set to trail
Dumbledore for a period as mentioned in
the following exchange between Harry and
Dumbledore scrim gur wanted to know
where you go when you're not at Hogwarts
yes he is very nosy about that he has
even attempted to have me followed
amusing really he set doors to tail me
it wasn't kind I have already been
forced to jinx tallish once I did it
again with the greatest regret anyway
while powerful Dawlish did fail quite a
few assignments towards the end of the
second Wizarding war the bottom line
that we should note is that these
failures were not necessarily the result
of magical ineptitude but more so the
fact that he had repeatedly faced far
superior ponents Dumbledore unfamiliar
situations Hagrid being a half giant and
continual placement under the look of
undischarged steam
you may remember Tina Goldstein from the
fantastic beasts films porpentine a--
AKA tina was an american half but witch
that attended ilver Mori School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry Goldstein was an
impressive student can became an aura
for the magical Congress of the u.s.
makuta the u.s. equivalent of the
Ministry of Magic
Tina was trusted by Mikasa and because
she proved herself as a witch she was
assigned by them to help the friendship
ministry with tracking down obscure ilk
readings baboon what I feel really
warrants Tina's placement on this list
was her ability to on numerous occasions
hold her own against skelet Grindelwald
first when she jewels Grindelwald while
disguises graves
even though Grindelwald was likely
holding back to some extent tina still
showed exceptional magical ability as
most would have just crumbled in the
same circumstance
Grindelwald after all was an immensely
powerful Dark Wizard the second time
that Tina really proved to us that she's
powerful was when she held back
Grindelwald protego diabolica using a
shield charm tina was also exceptionally
powerful at apparition nonverbal magic
transfiguration divination charms
defense against the dark arts and joy
given how she handled herself in quinn
der waals presence i don't think that
you can argue that she isn't one of the
most powerful auras round number three
Kingsley Shacklebolt
Kingsley Shacklebolt was a British
pureblood wizard order of the Phoenix
member powerful aura and later Minister
for magic Shacklebolt attended Hogwarts
and performed particularly well on his
newts fulfilling all the necessary
qualifications to become an aura
Shacklebolt was trusted enough at the
ministry to fulfill a variety of
extremely important duties including
guarding the muggle Prime Minister and
along with Dawlish traveling with fudge
to attend to business matters Kingsley
was a high-ranking aura and displayed a
very powerful and balanced arsenal of
magical capabilities choco-balls fellow
Order members held him in high regard
and even Lord Voldemort himself
considered Kingsley to be a powerful
wizard if that isn't an indicator of his
level of power then I don't know what is
Shacklebolt
exhibited natural cunning outstanding
dueling ability full defense against the
dark arts proficiency charms mastery
Transfiguration mastery potions mastery
apology mastery apparition flying
mastery and more he truly was a master
of all and was able to comfortably hold
his own against at least two Death
Eaters at once in fact during the Battle
of the seven Potters Shacklebolt was
chased by five Death Eaters and even
though he was primarily focused on
protecting Hermione he was able to stun
two of them and escaped with mastery in
all magical forms and a testimonial from
Lord Voldemort himself that Chaka bought
was powerful I don't think that his
placement on this list can be questioned
number two Rufus Scrimgeour
Rufus Scrimgeour was a British pureblood
Wizard veteran Ora and later Minister
for magic he attended Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry and excelled in
all subjects easily meeting the aura
eligibility requirements after crushing
his newts scrim COS spent most of his
life as
defeating dark witches and wizards for
years and it was through years and years
of practice that he came to achieve his
level of magical power skim gur was in
Dumbledore's words a man of action and
was far more decisive than his
predecessor Cornelius fudge
before becoming Minister for magic Rufus
was the head of auras this title alone
speaks to his ability to handle himself
his level of expertise and his inherent
magical capability as head of a division
that focuses on capturing dark wizards
we can only assume that his magical
proficiency was truly a step above those
underneath him and perhaps the most
relevant testament to scream his
capabilities he was able to put up a
valiant effort against the Dark Lord
Voldemort one of the most powerful
Wizards to have ever lived though
Scribner was defeated giving someone as
powerful as Voldemort a fight is an
extremely notable accomplishment in and
of itself number one Alastor Moody at
the top of this list we have Alastor
Moody one of the most famous auras of
all time Alastor Moody was a pureblood
wizard and is considered by many to be
the most famous aura of all time he was
an order of the Phoenix member dark
wizard catcher and warrior moody served
with great distinction during the first
visiting war and lost an eye
leg and nose in battle against evildoers
Moody is personally responsible for a
large number of the witches and wizards
in Azkaban and this earned him quite the
reputation amongst the dark wizard
community
Alastor Moody was hired as Defense
Against the Dark Arts professor by
Dumbledore in 1994 but before starting
his new posting was ambushed in his home
by Barty Crouch jr. and Peter Pettigrew
though he fought valiantly the
surprising nature of the attack led to
his eventual downfall and he was trapped
inside of his very own magical trunk it
is my personal opinion that party Crouch
jr. is one of the most powerful Death
Eaters of all time and even though we
don't see him exercising his magical
capabilities too much I think that he
had a lot more in him than what we were
shown for this reason it makes sense
that along with Pettigrew Crouch jr. was
able to capture the
Alastor Moody moody was incredibly brave
but also extremely powerful particularly
in his prime
many feel as though his abilities may
have peaked during the first visiting
war and that he had dropped down a peg
by the time the second Wizarding war
came around the result of years of hard
battling similar to Shacklebolt
moody was regarded as one of the most
powerful members of the order of the
Phoenix by Lord Voldemort himself for
this reason
Voldemort suspected that moody was
likely the wizard protecting Harry
during the Battle of the seven potters
and was initially targeted by Voldemort
for this reason it was only after Moody
was defeated that Voldemort pursued
Shacklebolt
which tells me that Voldemort likely
felt that Moody was the more powerful of
the two though Moody was killed by
Voldemort if he wasn't paired with
manago's Fletcher he may have survived
the killing curse that hit Moody was
intended for mangas but when mangas dis
operated it hit moody killing him
instantly
Moody's magical Arsenal was not limited
in any way and he had no chinks in his
armor he was a master of dark arts
defence against the dark arts dueling
charms Transfiguration potions herbology
apparition flying non verbal magic and
even Aquaman see for all of the reasons
listed above I feel that he was the most
powerful aura of all time and that
concludes the list of the top five most
powerful auras extremely honorable
mentions include Harry Potter and in
fedora Percival graves
Theseus commander Ron Weasley Frank and
Alice Longbottom and others I think that
you could definitely make arguments for
substitutions in this list but I felt
good about my final result and that
concludes the video what do you guys
think of these rankings let me know down
in the comment section below until next
time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
you